hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and it's John over here so over on
patreon.com slash the real rejects one
of our reward tiers is that whatever
video you access to do a commentary on
or do a reaction to whatever the hell it
is you want we will definitely do except
for do that thing PewDiePie once did on
Fiverr that we won't do other than that
that's with John no time to give you a
hold on and resharpening he wanted us to
check out adam episode 2 by mo studios
the mirror episode so to understand this
we have to find episode what you could
have find on out studios I did some
research
you know typed in a word and I
eventually found episode 1 which was on
the unity channel so we did a reaction
over on patreon for that and now we have
an understanding of what it is yeah then
that video dropped last year and it got
pretty some viral attention I mean I saw
it shared around a lot and it's been
over well over a year since episode 1
now it's at out studios I don't know
what happened with Adam and I didn't do
more research after filming it to find
out why all that was going on
who needs do do it who needs to do all
that so we're gonna watch episode 2 now
we'll talk about it
unity again unity you know it's funny
because I felt like the Adam 1 then part
1 was about unity in some ways Oh see if
the graphics got better
whoa
oh he's leading the robots
he's like Moses
three the people
[Music]
[Music]
behind
come on apocalypse
[Music]
wait Oh y'all are a bunch of douche bags
so for Adam Adam still human empathy
[Music]
I think it's over there
[Music]
I want to do that
[Music]
is this a videogame chappie
she's like Neil Blomkamp's Maze Runner
[Music]
oh he needs to live in the wallet city
of the consortium you were cut away from
your bodies you can't remember because
the consortium wiped your mind what's
that
and nearer reads the traces of your mind
[Music]
that's made like that
what the hell's going on with our
eyeballs article 1-1 felony treason
article 1-1 B felony terrorism
cries against the consortium a terrorist
attack to come
[Music]
[Music]
mm-hmm
I can't wait for another year and a half
to fight this one okay I co-wrote this
one too yeah sweet that's cool man that
is cool
these are intriguing little slivers of a
story are you gonna wait a year and a
half for the next one it's entirely
possible because we waited here waited
over a year and I came out June of last
year yeah I wonder how long it took for
them to actually make this because I
remember seeing some of their social
media posts being like oh you know we're
excited to show you guys this next short
you know it's gonna be rendered in the
unity engine and stuff yeah
vocab oh they mocap it huh at least some
is the first one that I have credits
this is cool man yeah this is cool some
neat things over that oats studios
honestly I didn't I really appreciated
the first one yeah yeah it's like a mood
pieces as I cleverly put it but I wasn't
like oh you know the one of these yeah
that though made me go yo-yo so I had to
have a third rhyme that one really built
up something much more showing there's
there's a lot more to its mythology and
its story yeah cuz I'm like well the
first one might have just been some cool
little short story yeah and a good way
to test out into shows south of your
engine and it's a good body language
piece here the the information was still
really cool you still get a lot of like
the first half is really just body
language before you start getting its
the explanation of who the robots are we
kind of concluded that these are former
criminals who were turned into like
these machines to possibly enslave I got
the sense talent to use the body parts
dump the rest yeah yeah yeah and the
batteries run out but would really
intrigued me here I mean that first part
when they're walking through the the
wasteland with fire and then that one
machine was like dying
yeah I really love Adam I do I love Adam
I don't know what it is about him he
just seems so sympathetic you know it's
all in his eyes he's really sad I love
his little pupils open and ya dilate and
contrast and the body language like you
said I feel for the guy especially
because of that great opener from
episode one where you're like oh this
guy's realizing he's like waking up to
that and then the sequence where dr.
doom slash apocalypse does not kill the
robot yeah checks her out and yeah and I
almost got the senses like me it's
nothing I can do here yeah because I
keep thinking this person's evil and
maybe I'm racist or something and again
I'm chunky Robo against chunky giant
robots
like look like apocalypse and dr. Dave
got that like I almost thought it was
like a wing or something and they didn't
like to like destroy her or something I
thought I was gonna like crusher like
yeah leave her be hi there's no point in
going then he says he chooses life yeah
I was like okay maybe he's a good guy I
love it for the part three when that
comes out in three and a half years
discovery is like the worst version of
24 you get an hour season of TV that was
neat because we've seen that done before
worse someone turned into a machine
human Marcus Wright the potential
squandered there with that sequence it
was done in such a fascinating way where
as he was learning this stuff I know
Marcus Wright comes to mind but a lot of
times when they whenever I've seen
stories do something like that you see
who they are beforehand and then they
get turned into a machine this one's
more intriguing because we have no idea
who he is beforehand and they don't even
know yeah and you build this weird and
harun sympathy in the first in the first
piece because you're like they're all
just kind of being pushed out into the
world after this completely jarring
experience and yet to have it be like I
just discovered these new circumstances
of what my consciousness is and now I'm
about to learn who I was who you were
and then as he's learning it I was
thinking but you wanted to be think yeah
you were turn into this because you're
considered one of the worst of the worst
you know would you want to know just how
bad you are or do you want to just live
a new life or this just add to your
misery that you already feel knowing I
all I remember is I was human and that's
a conundrum because yeah like once
you're in this robot body I gotta
imagine that's it it would be hard to
make that decision I want to know who I
might have been but also oh God
what did I do what am I gonna feel
guilty for now you know in hindsight and
am I gonna rediscover the things that
made me do that by learning about it now
and I'm really glad too that they that
the story is going down a path not you
know the Tyrell corporation like seeing
the Society of the humans controlling
robots but it's like now this other
robot shows up as like yo on Moses y'all
free now now it's like oh there be gonna
be mentored and learn to adjusted or a
lifestyle from an another machine who
freed them from the people that turned
them or maybe this is all part of the
program yeah it's intriguing it's
intriguing guy making stuff and I mean
just the world you know you always got a
touch on the world and you know the this
idea it seems like there are almost
pockets of civilization cuz you had I
don't know exactly what part of the
consortium that compound was but you've
got that compound and then you've got
this barren burning desert you know and
then this other little compound
you know the robots are all sort of
congregating and I'm like what else is
in this world now given the fact that
they pointed out you know the Unity
engine yeah it looks beautiful and this
one is is a step up from the first one
and the first one look great already
look great yeah well hell yeah hell yeah
it's a unity and oats studios guys this
stuff is awesome
this is awesome I will keep a lookout
for six years from now for part three on
my deathbed hundred years from now that
I could finish the Atticus series this
will be like the series I watched
throughout my life
as Adam grows I to show ya alright guys
well thank you Angie Terpening first
singing this always this is really
worthwhile thank you thank you my
friends cool when you get a chance to
actually really comment on something and
a different type of matter subscribe to
the real rejects click on that
notification bell follow us on social
media links in the description box make
sure to check us out on the stardust app
download the app and follow us first 30
second reactions to any trailer film or
TV show and send us your jigsaw
reactions tag us and stardust on social
media and you might just be featured in
that review coming up this week don't
you want to be in a real rejects video I
don't
take care